breaking news i can tell you that the mp
accused of watching porn in the house of
commons is going to quit as an mp this
is
neil parish under growing pressure to go
let's uh bring in straight away our
political correspondent rob powell and
rob yesterday neil parish had vowed to
fight on while the investigation was
carried out but we understand that his
friends had really told him to go
putting this uh
making his position untenable
yeah a big change in position a u-turn
by neil parish the devon mp uh now
saying within 24 hours that he will now
resign uh as mp he had previously been
kicked out to the tory parliamentary
party there had been calls for him to go
as an mp he has now decided that is what
will happen uh a spokesperson for the
local conservative um association in
tibetan and honeton in devon the
constituency he for now anyway still
represents
says has confirmed that today
and also said we would like to take this
opportunity to thank neil parish for his
service to our communities over the past
12 years we support his decision to step
down as our member
of parliament now some comments that he
has made
in his resignation are starting to come
out it appears mr parish has spoken to
the bbc and um and said that admitted uh
that he had watched pornography and said
that it had been a moment of madness and
that he was not proud of what he was
doing he said the first time uh was
accidental after looking at tractors but
the second time was deliberate
you